[Musique]
oh
les pôles sont calmes c'est normal elles
connaissent mireille maintenant elle
vient au poulailler tous les matins
mireille le roux vient de faire le saut
elle reprend la ferme familiale
nous sommes dans la municipalité de
fournier en ontario à 35 ans elle arrive
presque sur le tard après ses études mme
mireille avait enseigné au campus
d'alfred et sa passion pour
l'agriculture
elle l'a vivait dans sa ferme est auto
cueillette de pommes et citrouilles
moi mon projet initial c'était notre
verger pour faire de l'agrotourisme
puis est venu l'occasion de revenir à la
ferme donc je suis décidé de revenir à
la fable mais j'ai gardé le verger en
même temps que je vais encore de la
gontrie et de la gestion de son père se
retrouver proche de la retraite sans
relève
il a offert sa ferme à sa fille alors
mireille a dit à son père je me lance
mais ce sera une production 2 biologique
j'aurai besoin de toi pour construire
les nouveaux poulaillers et on construit
à fournier et non à l'emplacement de la
ferme familiale au village voisin de
saint-isidore de c'est beaucoup plus
prêt physiquement de mon vers l'est donc
j'habite même pas 1 km d'ici puis aussi
c'est les aider au transfert la valeur
des terres ici est un peu moindre que la
firme actuel puis en plus de ça latta
russie étaient certifiés biologiques dès
le début sur le peu de caudry beaucoup
plus et jetez la construction des
nouveaux bâtiments et la phase 1 du plan
de relance et chez son père marcel qui
supervise les travaux pour toute la
construction ça a été mon gérant
j'appelle ça mange léger radjati fait
que oui une chose qui est là parce que
on n'aurait pas le projet si les
poulaillers de la relève se distingue de
la ferme familiale
c'est un nouveau type de bâtiment propre
à la régie d'élevage biologique voulait
aller dans le bios moi je réponds tu es
dans le bios mon âge mais elle a son âge
on a décidé d'aller dans le projet que
vous la peinture laquée un peu dans mon
idée c'est une ferme avicole de
dimension moyenne en ontario deux
poulaillers avec 12500 poulpe arpents
douars et un bâtiment de 13 mai le
poussin en élevage by a marqué dans mon
idée une fois qu'on était capable de
sécuriser un contrôle pour vendre mother
il vous me voulez heureuse dans la façon
que j'allais travailler donc on était
capable de s'organiser pour monter le
projet avec mes valeurs puis avec sa
vision on était capable de joindre les
deux enfants
ils ont opté pour le logement appelé
système aviaire les poules vol du
parquet à laitages pour pondre derrière
les rideaux dans l'intimité
on en est venu à la conclusion qu'on
aimait mieux l'ambiance pour les oiseaux
sous systèmes via la facilité du travail
aussi pour nous donc c'est comme le
meilleur des deux mondes
autant pour les oiseaux que pour nous
pour travailler avec les oiseaux
elle a voulu les équipements des toutes
dernières technologies
j'aime beaucoup de nouveautés comme
l'échangeur d'air commercial récupérer
la chaleur du conte à la bâtisse on veut
minimiser ce chauffage on veut baissé
l'humidité baissière dont ont été
cherchés système de deschamps jardin de
la france
mais
même la couleur foncée des poulaillers
et stratégiques
je ris beaucoup de la couleur de même
bâtiment mais il ya une fonction à la
couleur des bâtiments ça réchauffe l'air
à l'intérieur comme on a moins d'oiseaux
ça aide
ça va couper les coûts de chauffage ont
plus du chauffage dans un pont douar bio
chapron des fenêtres pour la lumière des
portes pour les sorties extérieures des
oiseaux et encore d'autres ajouts
nombreux qui dans un bâtiment
conventionnel ce qui peut représenter
50% d'investissements de plus à la
construction
je ne saurai pas assez
l'achat de la terre les bâtiments le
quota mireille a maintenant des
obligations financières
mais elle est reconnaissante du coup de
pouce de ses parents le transfert en
date d'aujourd'hui on pense que ça peut
prendre de 5 à 10 heures que ça soit
fait peut-être moins peut-être plus là
on va savoir un peu plus une fois qu'on
va se mettre le nez complètement la daps
ça se repose 100% un cadeau c'est
certain que pour être capable de faire
un transfert je sois capable de racheter
une partie qui va probablement est en
partie un cadeau comme on ne sait pas
encore exactement les détails mais si
c'était 100% acheté à valeur marchande
c'est plus difficile mais c'est certain
qu'en ayant une production biologique
qui me rapporte plus par tête de cauter
ça va me faciliter la vie pour pouvoir
raffarin n'est pas mal au pays la
majorité des fermes avicoles sont
transférées aux enfants de la famille
est très souvent à des filles
paris
- d
si une fille qui est français on n'est
plus le regard de sylvette et confiant
elle sait que sa fille va réussir à sa
manière à elle
pour essayer d'avoir un
jerry lara familiale lorrain et ferme
des fois si je pense qu on essaie de
s'organiser différemment que qui lisent
leurs méthodes elle avait quitté la
ferme mais le messie revient vite
mireille leroux a pris le contrôle de sa
destinée
elle est devenue agricultrice
[Musique]
les arabes sont pour partie c'est
certain que mes parents même avocat
double formé d
à mes tableaux comme ça
[Musique]
ça sera une très belle oui oui